Sequencer is Unreal Engine's multi-track editor used for creating and playing back
cinematic sequences in real time.
It's the backbone for all linear content creation in Unreal Engine and a production
hub combining aspects of an editorial department with layout and animation, all within a non-linear
timeline.
Sequencer, while it can be used for more traditional film-like applications, has
many other capabilities that are beneficial to real-time applications, such as video games.
For the purposes of this course, we'll create in-game cutscenes with pre-defined
camera angles, animation, and event triggers, however, it's important to note that a sequence
doesn't always have to include cameras, for example, you could use a sequence in-game
to play a building collapse instead of relying on chaos physics at runtime.
It's also important to note that sequences can be loaded and unloaded at real-time and
are independent of a level.
A well-defined framework and pipeline for your cinematics are essential for maintaining
a clean, organized, and accessible project.
A common structure for feature films is the use of a parent cinematic, commonly used
for viewing the entire cinematic as well as rendering the final output, and nested
sequences and shots.
Using a structure like this has many benefits for video game development, specifically,
this type of workflow enables multiple departments to work concurrently on shots
while preserving a well-organized file structure.
And while this structure works for video games and films, I strongly recommend that
you take time early on in your project to define a file and folder structure for
your in-game cutscenes, establish your shot, assembly, and nesting templates, as well
as define a pipeline that best suits your project.
Within our sequences, we have a few options for spawning or controlling various actors.
Specifically, there are three classifications.
Possessibles are actors that already exist in our level that can be included in our
sequence, allowing us to control various parameters for that actor.
For example, within our level, we may have a doorway that we need to have our actor
open.
We can include the door actor, or blueprint, in our sequence and animate the door opening
and closing.
After the sequence is complete, the door will still remain in the level.
Our second type is known as a spawnable.
Spawnable actors are only loaded when the sequence is playing and are removed after
the sequence is complete.
For example, let's say we have a sequence where we have a spaceship fly in to deliver
cargo and then it flies off afterwards.
Because we really only need the ship to appear during the sequence, using a spawnable actor
is the most logical choice as opposed to placing the ship in the level and trying
to control it and then hide it afterwards.
Lastly, introduced in 5.5 is a new type known as replaceables.
Replaceables are similar to spawnables, however they can be swapped at runtime.
For example, let's say that you have a game where players have the ability to customize
a character at any time throughout the game.
Rather than loading a generic actor into our sequence, we want to load the player's
specific character as it appears when the sequence starts.
By using a replaceable actor in your sequence, you can build and animate the sequence using
a reference actor and replace that reference actor with the player's character at runtime.
The same principle applies to any actor that's loaded into a sequence when it's defined
as a replaceable.